we are told that billy has one fourth of
a pound of trail mix he wants to share
it equally between himself and his
brother
how much trail mix would they each get
so pause this video and try to figure
that out
all right now let's work through this
together so billy starts with one-fourth
of a pound of trail mix so how could we
represent one-fourth
well if this is a whole pound
let's just imagine this rectangle is a
whole pound i could divide it into four
equal sections so let's see this would
be
roughly two equal sections and then if i
were to divide each of those into two
now i have four equal sections
so billy is starting with a fourth of a
pound draw a little bit try to make it a
little bit more equal
billy is starting with a fourth of a
pound so let's say that is that fourth
of a pound that he starts with he's
starting with one fourth of a pound and
he wants to share it equally between
himself and his brother so he wants to
share it equally between two people
right over here so we want to do is
essentially say let's start with our
total amount of trail mix and then we're
going to divide it into two equal shares
so when they ask us how much trail mix
would they each get it we're really
trying to figure out what is this
one-fourth divided by two
so what would that be well what if we
were to take all of these four equal
sections and divide them into two
so
i'll divide that one into two i will
divide this one into two i will divide
this one into two and then i would
divide this one into two and now what
are each of these sections well each of
these are now one-eighth that's a
one-eighth right over there these are
the whole is divided into eight equal
sections
and so you can see that when you start
with that one-fourth
and you divide it into two equal
sections so one
section and two equal sections right
over there each of those is equal to 1
8.
so 1 4 divided by 2
is equal to
1
8. let's do another example
so we are told matt is filling
containers of rice
each container holds 1 4 of a kilogram
of rice
and then they tell us if matt has 3
kilograms of rice how many containers
can he fill so like always pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
all right so let's think about what's
going on we're starting with a total
amount three kilograms of rice and we're
trying to divide it into equal sections
in this case we're trying to divide into
equal sections of one-fourth of a
kilogram
so we are trying to figure out what 3
divided by 1 4 is going to be equal to
now to imagine that let's imagine three
wholes this would be three whole
kilograms so that is one
whole
this is two holes trying to make them
all the same but it's hand drawn so
it's not as exact as i would like so
that's three whole kilograms here and he
wants to divide it into sections of
one-fourth so if you divide it into
fourths how many fourths are you going
to have well let's do that
so let's see if we were to divide it
into halves it would look it would look
like this
if you divide these three wholes into
halves but then if you want to divide
into fourths
we it would look like
it would look like this i'm trying to
get it close to equal sections
they should be exactly equal sections so
i am almost there
so
there you have it
so i've just taken three wholes and i've
divided into fourths so how many fourths
are there well there are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 4. so 3 divided by 1 4 is
equal to 12.
and i encourage you to really think
about why this is the case that if you
take a whole number like three and you
divide it by one fourth we're getting a
value larger than three and we're
getting a value that is four times three
think about why that is the case